the cannibal sharks investigation heads
to Bimini in the Bahamas the mangrove
swamps here are a precious nursery for
lemon sharks every year scores of
pregnant females return to these shallow
waters where they were born to give
birth
[Music]
but in a Machiavellian twist that
surprised scientists someone was eating
the kids of a hundred newborn sharks
born in June of one year by June the
next year around 50 are left so 50
percent of the cohort in every year are
eaten or died from starvation this pot
is less than 2 feet long one of a litter
of up to 17 pups scientists from the
Bimini shark lab have been studying the
lemons here for more than 20 years
they found the pups can stay up to 8
years here learning to hunt and hide
among the twisted mangrove roots but the
shocked discovery was the pups biggest
threat comes from their own
everything seems to kick off at high
tide as the water rises it basically
gives access to shallow water areas for
big predators to come in as well that's
when these big lemon sharks come in and
stop patrolling and cruising the
outskirts of those mangroves
the young are on high alert
they instinctively hugged the mangrove
roots which offer some protection but if
they stray too far the hunt is on for a
baby lemon shark that's in close
proximity to a big adult if they haven't
seen it before its seen them they've got
no chance we can first attack very
quickly an ambush really effectively
I've seen firsthand bite marks I've seen
adults chasing juveniles you know we
know it's happening it's clear evidence
shark cannibalism goes on in the wild
but why would you eat your own the one
great advantage that an adult lemon
shark has is insider knowledge on where
the juveniles are hiding and what
tactics they use to avoid predators
because it's been one itself and that
gives it an extra advantage and and
probably why they then pick off the
juveniles of their own species what's
happening here in Bimini isn't unique
throughout the world in other nursery
areas big sharks are eating little
sharks
it comes down to needing to eat why
would they not take advantage of that
resource and now new research suggests
this has been happening for millennia
[Music]